Michael do you know what the leading
cause of death for pregnant people is
pregnant people
mothers women if you'd like to call them
mothers not all of them are mothers but
if you'd like to call them that what are
they if they're not mothers they're
pregnant people what what people other
than mothers are pregnant does it bother
you to use inclusive language it's just
interesting I prefer to use precise
language it's interesting because you
come into this conversation you know
trying to hold this moral superiority
but then when I when I try to be moral
when I can but right but when I use
inclusive language which it only takes a
couple extra syllables to use inclusive
language it seems to include people who
don't you know identify as women but can
become pregnant
so
like a person who's born a woman and
then identifies as a man and is pregnant
yeah so you're telling me that in order
to be a moral person I need to accept
the idea that a man someone who is born
a man who looks like a man can really
become a woman that's that's a
prerequisite of my being a moral person